what's amazing to me is you can pretty
much do play-by-play for
hockey
uh horse races football baseball and
it seems to me
you would have to watch every one of
these games and read the newspaper in
the sports section and keep up if
someone said to you right now
okay uh we want you to switch from
football to basketball you would have to
ramp up right i mean you would have to
sure a deep dive study right
i would listen whatever you do i mean
you have to study it uh you know when i
signed on with abc in 1977 full-time the
first assignment i mean they're going
around the world doing this and that and
i can't wait i hadn't been to europe in
my life at that point i'm in my early
30s
they sent out the assignment sheet
what's the first assignment i get at abc
i'm doing the world
barrel jumping championships
in northwest in northbrook illinois a
suburb of chicago what the hell every
chris schenkel is going over to saint
risk frank giffords and kitzbuhel these
are the other guys are in japan i'm
going to freaking northbrook illinois
for barrel jumping but at least if
somebody said to me at least they gave
you world barrel jumping not regional
barrel jumping so i kind of broke down
the big time you make a good point
though and my father used to tell me
this with broadcasting he said to me you
know i don't care what dumpy radio
station you're at you got a you got to
be doing that brooke's because you never
know who's watching and i bet when you
did barrel jumping you said damn it if
they're going to give me barrel jumping
i'm going to study this thing i'm going
to find out who's the best right you put
your heart into it
no question you have to and you're so
right because you know i started my
career actually in hawaii doing minor
league baseball now you think that's an
outpost but it's not because a lot of
people would come over there
and they'd be on vacation and i was on
television i was doing the games on
radio and a couple of people heard me
and that is how i wound up going from
the miners in hawaii to the major
leagues with the cincinnati reds in 1971
because
the right guy heard me and recommended
me to cincinnati when they were looking
for an announcer and that was the
launching pad for me because i had pete
rose johnny bench tony perez joe morgan
i had the big red machine i got to do
when i'm 27 years old howard i did the
world series on nbc in those years the
team announcer would join kurt gowdy and
tony kubick on nbc in the world series
and i swear when we came on camera
and kurt's going to introduce me all i
could think about in my brain was please
god please when i open my mouth let air
come out
and it did and then once yeah once you
get rolling it's unbelievable so what's
amazing to me is the book ends here too
i did the world series with the
cincinnati reds in 72
and the super bowl with the cincinnati
bengals in 2022